This entire course, I'm going to focus
on the problem of classification.
Classification is the task of taking
an input, like this letter, and
giving it a label that says,
this is a B.
The typical setting is that
you have a lot of examples,
called the training set,
that I've already been sorted in.
This is an A, this is a B, and so on.
Now, here's a completely new example.
And your goal is going to be to
figure out which of those classes
it belongs to.
There is a lot more to machine
learning that just classification.
But classification, or
marginally prediction, is the central
building block of machine learning.
Once you know how to classify things,
it's very easy, for
example, to learn how to detect them,
or to rank them.